[Musique]
si vous le refusez monsieur c'est une
amende donc c'est pas raisonnable c'est
une amendement
monsieur je suis avec ma petite fille de
4 ans je dois l'emmener à l'école je
suis non voyant c'est un chien guide
vous êtes obligé de le prendre monsieur
c'est quoi votre principe
alors voilà alors cherféline donc on va
on va reprendre toute l'histoire vous
arrivez à l'adresse pour récupérer
Anthony c'était votre première course de
la journée ouais il était quelle heure
c'était il nous avait dit
8h48 vous arrivez d'où je suis des 15e
j'ai déposé mes enfants voilà d'accord
vous allez le chercher où déjà
d'accord
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
VTC 125 ans d'accord vous n'avez jamais
eu aucun souci
on en parlera également dans un instant
Brahim il a toujours eu il y a jamais eu
de problème avec sans faire 5 ans qu'il
exerce à ma connaissance il a jamais eu
de problème vous le connaissiez avant
oui effectivement d'accord et donc c'est
qui c'est quelqu'un qui a jamais eu
d'antécédent enfin moi je représente
énormément de chauffeurs ses camarades
témoignent aussi comme moi on n'a jamais
entendu de quoi que ce soit de sable que
c'était un des chauffeur voilà qui qui
était
sans problème je veux faire sans
problème après moi j'ai été étonné je
lui ai dit alors on va en parler
de ce qui s'est passé alors
on va voir deuxième vidéo une passante
infirmière était la visiblement et vous
a dit que vous étiez dans l'obligation
de prendre le chien dans votre voiture
regarde
[Musique]
voilà donc il y a cette personne qui
arrive donc là vous allez donc le
chercher
au départ ça se passe bien vous voyez il
est avec sa petite fille ça
filme avec lui aussi d'accord
donc sa fille est donc le chien la
chienne voilà qui était là donc au
départ au départ vous allez chercher
vous savez pas qu'il y a un chien
oui moi je savais pas parce que c'est
l'application je mets pas les animaux
que je suis allergique
vous vous dites quoi moi je pense pas
parce que c'est non voyant ou pas c'est
ça les moi je suis choqué que je reviens
avec des téléphones et en train de
filmer et après il présentait que il
était avec les timel vaillant voilà je
suis choqué comment en train de filmer
j'ai discuté monsieur je peux pas
il a un chien aveugle
moi du coup j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qui
est voilà tapé sur le la fenêtre je vais
pas laisser en bas au début tout au
début il dit comment on aveugle il dit
que c'est un chien compagnon oui la
fenêtre
nous c'est avant la bagarre comme vous
le voyez avec un chien où il y a marqué
chien aveugle là vous voyez que c'est un
aveugle moi j'ai surprises
on va on va revenir sur tout ça donc
un moment donc il va pour rentrer dans
la voiture
vous filmez
en fait sur l'application dieber
normalement n'importe quel client il y a
un chien ou c'est handicap ou quelque
chose il lui présenter mais si est-ce
que vous pouvez prendre un chien ou
quelque chose avant d'arriver de
chauffeur moi j'ai rien reçu mais c'est
mon application il y a pas de je mets
pas les animaux
l'accepte ou non voilà alors pendant ce
temps il y a Anthony qui vous filme
parce qu'il arrive donc vous le voyez
avec son chien tout de suite vous dites
je vais pas le prendre non c'est pas ça
moi j'ai des skate j'ai un vidéo aussi
j'ai filmé dans la voiture je lui dis
mais si je veux pas les prendre vous
voulez pas le prendre avec le chien
pourquoi non je suis allergique
c'est parce que
dans le débit quand je voulais je
parlais avec lui je lui dis monsieur
voilà je peux pas les prendre
c'était mar qué sur l'application
voilà et après finalement je lui ai dit
monsieur je vais le prendre je savais
pas en règle alors justement
finissez par accepter le chien d'abord
d'abord regarder il vous filme
n'acceptez pas vous lui demandez même de
supprimer la vidéo on va revenir d'abord
sur cette vidéo
alors voilà donc là vous n'acceptez pas
qu'il filme moi je suis sur qui monsieur
contre le monsieur comme ils disent
qu'il était avec comment il fait le
mieux comment il ouvrir la coffre les
deux portes arrières voilà je suis sûr
que je peux pas les prendre pourquoi
il m'agressif le côté droit et il y a
des choses qu'ils ont levé sur les
vidéos en fait ils ont pas fait alors là
si vous avez
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses des insultes
la voiture avant de descendre de la
voiture de lui démission voilà je suis
allergique je peux pas les prendre et
après quand je lui dis monsieur vous
pouvez
l'accepter finalement comme il y a une
erreur c'est de l'application ou quelque
chose parce que je savais pas les
messieurs ils ont pas présenté à
l'avance alors on va voir parce que
normalement vous acceptez vous finissez
par accepter mais après le vous changez
de ton et si vous sortez l'animal de
votre voiture et là c'est là que c'est
ça devient violent regarde
monsieur
pourquoi vous vous énervez comme ça
quand vous êtes énervé comme ça ben
c'est des clients comme ça on fait des
ils ont
[Musique]
insisté ils ont ils ont ils ont agressé
ils ont moins insulté je suis je suis
énervé je vous fais voilà mais pourquoi
quand il ouvre la porte et qu'il met le
chien dans la voiture là vous vous
devenez fou vous en pensez seulement
ils ont mis les chiens à la force dans
la voiture moi je connais l'autre côté
ils ont poussé sur mon cœur moi je suis
tombé sur la voiture derrière et après
je tourne l'autre côté j'ai descends les
chiens bah comment je peux l'accepte
mais
comment il est en train de filmer en
fait donc pour vous les pages
il y avait une petite fille de 4 ans
voyant pour penser que vous mais c'est
ça
est-ce que moi vous pensez que je suis
malvoyant ou pas la question que je vous
pose aujourd'hui maintenant tout de
suite
on me regardant comme ça en me servant
d'un téléphone est-ce que vous pensez
que je suis malvoyant ou pas
c'est la question que je vous pose
parce que moi ça m'attriste de voir ce
genre de choses parce qu'on peut il y a
différence degrés de malvoyance et le
problème c'est que moi si je vous dis
qu'aujourd'hui je suis malvoyant vous
pouvez me dire bah non vous pouvez
utiliser un téléphone là je peux
regarder mon heure mais la différence
pardon il y a différents
on parle pas de l'handicap de la
personne je voudrais juste recadrer non
mais est-ce que c'est pourquoi le chien
ce qu'il est obligé de le prendre le
chien bien sûr je connais bien la loi
voilà tu connais bien la loi
finalement je lui dis quand j'ai dit
sans la voiture je suis d'accord pour
prendre les chiens
les vidéos c'est les vidéos qui vous ont
dérangé
les vidéos parce que vous avez bien vu
que c'était énervé il fallait passer les
vidéos ça le problème c'est ça le
dérange c'est que je prends le chien au
début il dit tout de suite quand il
arrive il dit le chien va dans le coffre
et tu et vous lui répondez non j'ai une
allergie c'est là que ça foutu le bordel
et qu'il a filmé
dans le coffre c'est déjà premièrement
d'accord moi je vais vous expliquer
parce que c'est très important de
recadrer les choses premièrement un
animal on met pas dans un coffre oui une
vraie personne qui exerce dans le
transport de personnes ne met pas un
chien moi je j'exerce ce métier j'ai une
couverture d'accord je mets la
couverture sur le siège et je laisse
rentrer l'animal tout simplement parce
que c'est un animal c'est de la
maltraitance ensuite oui il y a une loi
l'article 88 de la loi de 1987 qui dit
que les chiens guides d'accord doivent
être autorisés dans tous les transports
peu importe il y a pas discuter monsieur
le sait il connaît la loi il sait que
c'est une faute nous on l'a dit je lui
dis que pour ma part je condamne parce
que il y a la peur il y a la pénibilité
il y a le stress il y a aussi le fait
que il découvre une personne qui filme
tout de suite donc il se dit mais c'est
un canular qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi ce monsieur là film non mais il
faut vraiment comprendre après il y
avait je le redis quand moi je comprends
l'histoire je comprends l'histoire je
parle avec Anthony ce monsieur là c'est
malheureux c'est triste il s'est fait
refuser cette prestation par des
chauffeurs VTC c'est pas qu'une fois ça
lui arrivait et lui il a pas compris
exactement il a filmé parce qu'il s'est
dit j'en ai marre voilà à chaque fois on
refuse ma course et c'est normal il a
raison
il faut que ça servait d'exemple parce
que tous les VTC n'ont pas le droit de
refuser cette prestation donc je le
redis encore une fois je ne condamne pas
cher pedine vous pourquoi en fait on a
envie de savoir pourquoi vous êtes
autant énervé
pour les insultes en train de filmer ils
ont ils ont moins accepté bien sûr je
vais m'énerver voilà pourquoi vous êtes
autant énervé parce que c'est les
banquettes de sa voiture non mais c'est
ça parce que vous avez dit 60000 € les
banquettes
il ouvre les deux portes arrière et avec
les coffres c'est pour ça voilà je suis
énervé toutes tes questions
bah on les a entendu on les a vu il y a
il retourne dans ton pays etc
pourquoi on les a pas cette vidéo
ça a été dit bon on les a alors
remettez-les
je l'accepte
de quelque chose que je vois pas
un taxi spécial ici pour les animaux
tu le vois en commander un pour toi
[Musique]
il y a pas de personne avec moi Anthony
avec la dame et la petite
elle vous dit oui ce qui est grave mais
j'ai lu votre plainte vous avez déposé
plainte pour violence et puis un jour
raciale et sur la plainte vous dites
vraiment explicitement que c'est Anthony
que vous reconnaissez que vous pourriez
identifier un jour qui a formulé ces
injures sur la vidéo excusez-moi c'est
pas lui c'est pas Anthony Anthony il
peut pas vous dire il peut pas vous dire
vous êtes arabe tout de suite il est
malvoyant il vous connaît à peine dès le
début c'est impossible
j'aime beaucoup de peine pour en tenir
ce soir et j'imagine le calvaire qui vit
au quotidien j'ai eu aussi un peu de
peine pour vous monsieur moi je me mets
à la place d'un VTC qui bosse 15h par
jour avec toi
tu fais des courses à 8 balles pour se
mettre 2 € dans la poche qui s'est
endetté pendant des années pour acheter
une voiture alors évidemment vous aurez
dû le prendre évidemment que c'est une
connerie mais de là à le taxer à le
traiter comme le pire des monstres on a
parlé aussi de maltraitance animale
pardon moi Dieu sait que j'adore les
chats je ne supporte pas qu'on tape un
chien etc sur la vidéo j'ai pas vu de
maltraitance dans tous les sens on le
voit pas donner un coup à chaque État
donc oui vous avez fait une connerie
après vous n'êtes pas un monstre et je
pense que ça témoigne de la détresse
dans laquelle vous êtes vous les VTC
aujourd'hui
ils sont traités comme des rapports
aujourd'hui parce qu'on parle de la loi
il y a aussi le Code civil c'est à dire
l'article 1242 qui dit que il y a un
préposé d'accord qui est ce monsieur là
d'accord et de l'autre côté il y a celui
qui donne la mission c'est à dire uber
aujourd'hui Hubert est aussi fautif
pourquoi bien sûr parce que Hubert de
part justement le fait qu'ils ont des
chauffeurs ils ne les ont pas informés
il y a le manque d'information et le
manque de formation
il doit prendre il doit prendre un en
voyant avec son chien désolé
pénibilité il faut le directeur
est-ce que vous regrettez bien sûr qu'il
regrette pourquoi vous regardez
qu'est-ce que tu veux là oh merde alors
quand on parle d'Hubert c'est devenu un
sujet de tabou ah non mais c'est ça
monsieur tout à l'heure pendant la pause
s'il y avait une sanction il m'a dit il
est viré donc voilà mais c'est pas ça
non c'est vrai bah oui il a été viré il
était déconnecté et je vous rappelle
qu'il est présumé innocent donc il fait
la justice le mal qui fait sur tous les
autres VTC qui font bien leur boulot
mais qu'est-ce que vous auriez envie de
dire à Anthony soir est-ce que c'est
vrai que c'est ça des Manous donc je
vais vous dire ça nous fait de la
énormément de peine pour moi la chienne
et aujourd'hui on a connu ou quelque
chose moi finalement même quand je
descends après tout ça malgré là il
commence maintenant
en train de filmer compte juste du son à
la voiture je lui dis bien monsieur je
vais les prendre vous inquiétez pas
je comprends pas pourquoi dès le début
la personne elle va en fait si elle a eu
des mauvaises expériences je comprends
tout à fait qu'elle la file je comprends
si votre positionnement que ce que en
fait il vous exploite Hubert je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ça et je
comprends si moi je me mets à la place
des deux comme il disait Guillaume que
au bout de plusieurs refus ils se
mettent à filmer pour qu'on les croit et
pour qu'on croit ces personnes là et euh
que ça se reproduise pas parce qu'il
donc il y a des choses qui changent en
France voilà c'est pareil voilà mais je
comprends pas pourquoi au début vous
l'avez vous il vous dit qu'il est
malvoyant ou aveugle et sur le chien il
y a un arceau ou c'est écrit chien
d'aveugle ou chien d'accompagnement je
comprends pas moi je savais pas oui
monsieur
qui marche bien derrière
dans la voiture
il en convient lui-même il aurait dû
l'accepter
vous regrettez aujourd'hui de ne pas
l'avoir avant que cette vidéo
je suis d'accord regrettez aujourd'hui
de pas l'avoir accepté bien sûr bien sûr
si ça se reproduisait demain vous avez
la même scène avec un autre une autre
personne malvoyante vous vous faites
quoi avec un chien
moi je vais l'accepter mais il va pas
dire
excusez-moi
aujourd'hui il est venu d'accord
s'exprimer et dire qui reconnaît cet
ordre et je vous le redis il le sait
moi-même en tant que représentant je lui
ai dit tu as manqué tes obligations
c'est ça oui mais il faut pas maintenant
il faut dire aussi une chose il y a
aussi des gens qui sont responsables
dont la plateforme elle est d'accord je
vous rappelle le Code civil d'article
1242 d'accord donc il est en mission
pour Hubert il est censé être au moins
informé il n'a pas été informé d'accord
il doit prendre un chien
franchement il aurait dû prendre le
chien
là c'est on s'en fout de
GTA pour les défenses depuis des années
depuis des années 70
nous-mêmes moi je vais vous dire tout de
suite excusez-moi je me permets juste
moi je suis travailleur handicapé
d'accord je me depuis des années on
s'est battu devant le ministère des
Finances pour justement dire arrêter
d'exploiter des travailleurs handicapés
qui travaillent 90 heures semaine il
faudrait adapter excusez-moi et aussi on
en parlera juste pour vous dire Monsieur